another milestone for Cristiano Ronaldo
becoming the first man to score at five
World Cups helping Portugal beat Ghana
in the week he became a free agent
after his acrimonious exit for
Manchester United he's now attracting
interest from Saudi Arabia
do you want Cristiano Ronaldo to play in
the Saudi League who wouldn't want him
to play in their league uh you know he's
a role model to a lot of young players
him and Messi I'd love to see them both
play in the Saudi league and and you
know top players coming to the Saudi
league and play because that will you
know reinforce the programs that we're
doing it will showcase that you know the
league is strong Saudi Sports Minister
Prince abdulaziz bin turkey al-faisal
spoke to Sky News as they look to
accelerate investments in sport with
Newcastle already owned by The Sovereign
wealth fund Manchester United and
Liverpool are currently for sale
that anyone in the Kingdom who would
want to buy them I don't know I hope so
if there are investors and the numbers
add up and it makes a good business then
then the private private sector could
come in and we will benefit Sports and
Saudi will benefit from these
collaborations and these ownership
because we do exchange programs already
with with Newcastle and with our
connections around the world would
Manchester United be more desirable for
a Saudi to own do they have more fans
than Liverpool sayings Saudi Arabia I
really don't have the numbers but
Liverpool has been you know they've I
think increased in the past couple of
years their performance have been really
outstanding and and and I think they've
increased their fan base in in the
Kingdom especially with the performance
of Manchester as well Saudi fans have
been celebrating beating Argentina at
the World Cup while the kingdom explores
bidding for the 2030 tournament with
Egypt and Greece
would it be islamophobic for a sporting
body to impose regulations and you have
to serve alcohol at your tournament if
you are to be awarded the right well I
think yes because you know the World Cup
is for everyone and it's for and we live
in different parts of the world what's
what is accepted in in our part of the
world will not you know some of the
things will not be accepted in in the
East and some of them will not be
accepted into us FIFA hosting would
bring sharper scrutiny of the human
rights record the murder of the
journalist Jamal khashoggi in a Saudi
consulate in Istanbul in 2018 sparked
Global outrage is it fair that it's
still brought up can you understand why
the murder The Unexplained questions the
culpability is brought up in relation to
Saudi Sports Investments everyone was
horrified by the by what happened and
and everyone condemned it in the in the
kingdom is that one the biggest regrets
the fact that actually
this murder has actually damaged your
attempt to invest in sports because it
brought us up we know that Saudi Arabia
since you know a couple of years ago has
changed a lot so we know that we're
changing towards the future and I'm sure
that you know as you've seen a lot of
reforms are happening in the South and
Saudi and uh you know to make sure that
we the such a thing never happens again
through Sports Saudi Arabia hopes to be
seen in a new light Rob Harris Sky News
Doha